okay welcome back to the last stop of
the morning session former Georgia Tech
student professor recently recruited by
Yale wish noise
thank you all for being here so this
talk is going to be about the capacity
function which was which which came up
very prominently in good witch's work
and you know it has connections with
real stability and it was used to prove
non-trivial
inequalities and also computational
results for various accounting problems
including the prominent so I'm going to
tell you a little bit about the problem
that I'm going to be interested in the
motivation for it probably I'll skip and
then I'll talk about how we can
generalize Gurwitch this notion of
capacity to our setting which we're
interested in and then at the end talk
about how can we compute these objects
deterministically using techniques from
convex optimization so this talk will be
a little bit of polynomial it's a little
bit of convex optimization and the pine
thing is entropy so the problem that I'm
interested in is the following so you're
given a polynomial which is let's say
for the sake of this talk of multi
linear polynomial and you can express it
in this manner so P sub alpha are the
coefficients corresponding to the
monomial alpha and you're also given
some subset or family of monomials B
we'll talk a bit more about how these
are specified but as of now just think
about these given to you mathematically
and the computational problem that we
interested in is to find the sum of the
coefficients of the polynomial
corresponding to the monomials present
in this specified family so I'm not
interested in all the monomials
of the polynomial but some subset
of it which is somehow described to me
succinctly so I guess that the the the
the perhaps the most basic case of this
problem is the permanent which is a
polynomial which has a you know it can
be described in this following setting
so so here is a polynomial which is so
if you're given a positive matrix a and
cross n matrix a what you can do is take
each of its row multiplied with a vector
of variables x1 to xn and that gives you
a linear form and then you can take the
product of the linear forms for all the
rows and that gives you a polynomial
it's easy to see that you can evaluate
this polynomial at any given point you
know this has a very small circuit or
algorithm to do this but this is not
really the permanent what is the
permanent is the coefficient of the
monomial X 1 X 2 dot dot xn which in our
in our language corresponds to
recovering the coefficient corresponding
to the monomial 1 1 1 1 1 ok so just a
single monomial in easily computable
polynomial can encode a pretty
interesting and hard object which is the
permanent more sophisticated examples of
these are mixed discriminant where which
is kind of the known diagonal case of
the prominent where now you're given a
bunch of positive definite matrices a 1
to a n each n cross N and you can look
at this polynomial which is the
determinant now instead of the product
of the sum of these matrices a J's when
multiplied with the jth variable and now
again if in this polynomial I recovered
the coefficient corresponding to the
monomial 1 1 1 I get what is called the
mixed discriminant this can be also used
as a definition of mixes criminal
however my interest in this problem
arose by this other agenda my research
agenda which is trying to control bias
in machine learning and I can talk
offline about it I don't say too much
about it but he
the problem is the following that you're
given a bunch of vectors let's say V 1
to V M each of them sit in D dimensions
and this is the matrix corresponding to
it B and so in particular there is a
probability distribution over these
vectors which is induced by what is
called the determinantal point process
on subsets of these vectors and the goal
is to be able to count or sample from
subsets of these vectors where there may
be some additional constraints on the
determinantal point process for example
the set of vectors could corresponds to
images of men and you know male and
female images and you may be interested
in sampling a subset which has a certain
intersection condition with males and
certain intersection condition with
females okay so this problem encodes and
very nicely various mathematical and
machine learning settings and that's
what we would be interested in so if you
did not understand this motivation I can
talk offline this is not a talking
machine learning so I skip that let's
talk a little bit about how this problem
could be specified so we already
mentioned that the polynomial P we
should be able to evaluate at any given
point so you give me a value x1 to xn
for x1 to xn and I should be able to
tell you the value and this in some
sense corresponds to the fact that the
polynomial has a small circuit which you
can use to compute it what about the
family B so in this case you can see
that the family B can be specified
explicitly as a list of monomials
however in more interesting cases when
the the family B itself is an
exponential sized object we can't really
expect to give you the entire list of
monomials and so then we do something
more interesting which is to look at the
convex hull of all the vectors in B and
give you in some sense the least
possible information about this object
which is the ability to separate over
this so what does that mean that if I
give you a point
either you should say that the point is
in the polytope and your answer should
be accompanied by a mathematical proof
or if it's not then you should give me a
hyperplane
such that the point is on one side of
the hyperplane and the the convex hull
of all these points is on the other side
of the body and this should be doable in
polynomial time with respect to the the
the dimension in which these objects set
so this is this is this is not a new
notion for I mean for the mathematicians
I mean this is what in combinatorial
optimization is one very generic way to
work with community oreal polytopes so
this is the setting that we would be
interested in and the question is how
well we can compute this now clearly
when there are such hard special cases
of this we can't really expect to do
this exactly the problem is sharply hard
and in fact likely to be even hard to
approximate and so what we will do is
develop approximation algorithms for
computing this the approximation ratio
will come from real stability and the
computability will come from writing
down relaxations for this which use
convex optimization okay let's get back
to perfect matchings in bipartite graph
and permanent because this is going to
be really the starting point for our
discussion on how we can even think of
writing a convex programming relaxation
for this polynomial problem that we
described so we go back to what guru
Bates did and I'm going to present your
reinterpretation of his result which
will allow me to generalize and write
down a relaxation in the setting that I
am interested in so that's the that's
what we are going to do for the next ten
fifteen minutes so let's just recall the
problem also of the permanent also
community really you think of you're
given a bipartite graph with n vertices
on the left and n vertices on the right
and maybe there are weights associated
to these edges which we call by a I J
and the weight of a perfect matching is
just a product of the weights in each of
each of the edges press
in that perfect matching and the
permanent is just a partition function
corresponding to this this object which
also if you plug in a IJ is equal to one
will also count the number of perfect
matchings in this bipartite graph
something that has come up a few times
already so this problem is one of the
central problems in theoretical computer
science some very historic results so
valiant was the first to observe that
this problem is sharply hard which means
that it's unlikely that there will be a
polynomial time algorithm to compute
this object and building upon a long
line of work
jerem sinclair and begorrah use
techniques of Markov chains to give an
algorithm which will arrive demise
algorithm which would approximate the
value of the permanent within a
multiplicative factor of 1 plus epsilon
for any specified value of epsilon and
the running time is polynomial in 1 over
Epsilon
and even before this there was a work by
linear sanborn it's key and victors and
which use very old ideas from dynamical
systems and particular scaling to give
an e to the N approximation to compute
this object permanent of a non-negative
matrix the interesting thing to note is
that there algorithm was also
deterministic so given the title of this
workshop is about deterministic counting
so this is this is this is still close
to the best deterministic algorithm that
we know how to compute the permanent
whereas this one is random I started so
let me now mention the result that I was
talking about of correlate so goo roots
you know
studied this object which is a bit
strange if you have never seen this
before but I guess here many people have
seen this before it's still you know
always when I look at it for the first
time it looks surprising so you consider
this polynomial P sub a for a matrix a
which is the product of the linear forms
corresponding to rose and divided this
polynomial by a product of excise and
let's say let's see what happens when we
minimize this polynomial divided by
product of excise over the positive
ortant okay it looks at the infimum or
x+ so this notation means that each
coordinate of X is positive and this is
what is called the capacity of the
polynomial and using the theory of you
know hyperbolic or real stable
polynomials guru it's proved that this
quantity here is a pretty good
approximation to the permanent of this
matrix kind of close to what linear
summer net ski Invictus improved the
question of course is can we compute
this object right so they they also had
an algorithm which could do that the
question of the continuum can we compute
this and this question is addressed in
Gurewitz is work as well so there is an
algorithm which you can use to compute
this capacity so I guess if I want to
generalize this notion of capacity to
the problem that I talked about given
that you can view the permanent as
computing a certain coefficient of this
polynomial which which fits in the
previous setting I need to answer a
bunch of questions so one is how you
know how can I think about this
relaxation you know in a more
interesting manner which will allow me
to generalize and once I have this how
can I guarantee an approximation and
then finally talk about the
computability so it turns out that the
so the conceptually hardest part is to
think about this once we have this this
is rather easily follows from guru's
word and the computability part is quite
non-trivial
I'll tell you a little bit about it in
though in the most general setting in
grubitz and telling it's it's it's it's
fine but once we generalize it to
arbitrary polytopes and general
polynomials the computability becomes a
real issue any questions so far
yeah so these will be you know
algorithms which are yeah I mean which
which are in the realm of convex
optimization and so things like a lip
side method or interior point method
yeah but in practice actually if you
want to make it faster it's completely
fine to do some I was looking for you're
sitting right here I was trying to find
you in the room you're sitting right
here okay great so let's so this is our
goal to generalize this theory to the
setting of polynomials and polytopes so
let's let's let's see what the
connection first is between counting and
entropy this is a connection that goes
back to Boltzmann in fact it's Boltzmann
says famous equation which is even on
his grave which I guess many people here
have seen if not I highly recommend so
so Boltzmann was thinking about the
second law of thermodynamics and
essentially these ideas can lead us why
are some slightly more sophisticated
convex duality to the following very
simple convex optimization
characterization of the permanent so now
let's look at the the object which I
call P sub P M where m is the set of all
perfect matchings in the in this
bipartite graph and P FM is just the
convex hull so this is just nothing but
the bipartite matching polytope or the
or as we know it's the Birkhoff one arm
and pollito okay
so this is an object that many people
here know and so you're given some
weight to each vertex and let's ask
ourselves the following question is
there so suppose I give you a point
theta which is inside the polytope okay
well a point inside the convex polytope
can be written as a convex combination
of its vertices potentially in many many
different ways one particularly nice way
to write it as a convex combination is
to take the one which maximizes the
entropy of the distribution induced by
the convex hull so if so if I write this
as 1/2 times this and 1/2 times 6 then
the entropy is I mean well I can't write
it as 1/2 times this and half times is
because this is this is outside but you
can imagine that if I write it as a
convex hull of its vertices the there is
a particular distribution that arises
and you can look at the entropy of that
and that's exactly this quantity here
which I call primal of theta so primal
essentially hints to the fact that there
is a dual that is coming of this object
and this is if I fix am this is a
concave function entropy is a convene
this is negative entropy actually so so
this is this is a concave function and
we are maximizing a concave function so
this is a convex function a convex
optimization and you can prove that if
the point theta is in the interior of
this poly tope then a certain duality
holds and well okay maybe I skipped this
fact you may ask first that what is the
point theta which maximizes the
entropies so if I look at this value and
I change theta throughout the polytope
which point maximizes the entropy any
ideas which point maximizes the entropy
damage of the moment Magnum from the
normal which responds to scale so it
says it's the following tha's so this is
this goes back to Shannon right that the
entropy maximizing distribution is the
uniform distribution what's the support
of this distribution the support of the
distribution is all perfect matchings so
if you pick the point which corresponds
to the the average of all the vertices
okay so take they take the same weight
on all the vertices and look at the app
you know look at the point that you get
that is the point that will maximize
this this objective function and and you
can prove that the value is exactly
equal to log of the problem what's the
problem with this why why is this not
and give you an algorithm I mean after
all there are rumors that convex
optimization is in polynomial time right
yeah so this is a convex program where
the number of variables is exponential
the number of perfect matchings can be
exponential so we don't know how to do
this well but there are if you are smart
enough and you know more you can say
let's take the dual and you can take the
dual of this program and this is what it
turns out to be what are potential
issues to optimize this for any theta
now here the number of variables so
lambda is a vector which is our matrix
however you want to think of it so the
number of variables is N squared at most
here the issue here is in computing or
evaluating this object and because it
essentially is kind of a cyclic thing to
evaluate this object or it gradient you
need to evaluate this quantity here
which is the same as some kind of a
permanent so you're not really getting
around this problem but yeah you can you
can prove you know that this duality
implies that if I look at the the
supremum over all points inside the
polytope of this object it is exactly
equal to the permanent so how do I get
from here to here I actually made a
transformation that CIJ is e to the
lambda IJ a hyperbolic transformation to
come down to this problem
this is not a convex optimization
problem this is what is called you're
basically convex optimization problem
where if you define the right metric
then you get this so this starts looking
more and more like what guru bits is
doing but still it seems not exactly the
same thing and in particular we neither
know how to evaluate this polynomial nor
do we know anything about the
aspect of it so so we will try to
simplify this and arrive at but the nice
thing about this interpretation is that
this has nothing to do with matchings
you can do this over any set of objects
any set of combinatorial objects so
let's look at this this thing that we
just derived the problem with this is
that you know the polynomial in that in
the numerator is hard to evaluate and
one observation about the the polytope
of apartheid perfect matchings is that
it's an in so VIPRE I prefer matching
the intersection of two matrix for those
of who you know what it means and in
particular that also implies that you
can write down this poly tope as the
intersection of two polytopes which are
the following so on the left hand side
you have this poly tope which
corresponds to column stochastic
matrices so for every column the sum of
all the entries is equal to one and the
right hand side correspond to row
stochastic matrices which and so if you
look at the intersection of these two
objects then you can recover back this
polynomial it has some structure which
is kind of interesting
so one thing we can do is to make this
polynomial a little bit more tractable
is to just restrict this or just relax
this to be only on one of one of these
poly tope so for example what I do here
is starting from this poly tope here I
consider this P tilde of Z which is just
a Newton poly tope with the appropriate
weights of of this poly tope
corresponding to m2 this now becomes
easy to evaluate and this is this is
also what I mean you know in some sense
what gu roots was doing and so basically
I had these two things here so theta
belonging to PM PM is an intersection of
two objects what I did was I moved one
object here and one object there so the
moment I realized I have an intersection
of two different combinatorial objects I
I considered this kind of a relaxation
where I now optimize theta over the
first poly tope and evaluate the
polynomial only at the second point so
technically this is not a relaxation
because I really can't prove that this
quantity is related at all to this but
this is a heuristic way to make your
polynomial optimization problem at least
now not suffer the consequences of that
I can't even evaluate the polynomial or
I canti valentim eyes over the polytope
okay so this there's nothing really
stopping us from going ahead and looking
at what happens with this with this so
one thing we can do is in this object we
can replace zi j's with x i for all j's
and the reason is that when we're
optimizing over theta which belongs to
this set of column stochastic matrices
it doesn't really
you can pick different Z's but you don't
have to because theta idea is sum up to
one for every column making this
replacement doesn't change the
optimization problem at all
and what you recover is exactly the
riches relaxation
so we made a conceptual jump from here
to here we observe that the optimization
problem and the polynomial are entangled
we kind of separated them out into two
different things moved one part of the
complexity here in the second part of
the complexity here and now both objects
become tractable and now we just do some
very simple substitution and arrive at
this quantity I don't know if this is
how you thought of it but perhaps not
this this that it's for the permanent
this association is a long story this
problem actually this was the way to
prove existence of seen for scaling due
to David London from - ok so that the
main kind of trust what they did was
that you can use the same four general
polynomial okay look forget about metric
structure
forget about motorist used for general
polynomials and magically it gives you
ability to prove oh so this was comfy
stood and now we will see that this this
way of looking at it very easily allows
us to generalize or come up with a
notion of capacity for the problem that
I showed you in the first slide it's not
clear that it is yeah yeah but it uses
the fact that this is I mean okay this
polynomial has additional special
properties for instance it's real stable
so but what is the making of yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah so if you remember let's
go back to the problem in the in the
beginning right that we had a polynomial
and we had a polytope right and these
two objects we wanted to intersect by
computer
the sum of the coefficients of the
polynomial restricted to this polytope
this is what we wanted to do so there
was always an intersection hidden
somewhere and if these two quantities
were a priori not tractable then this
problem anyway doesn't make sense so
we're assuming that the evaluation of
this polynomial is easy as well as
separation over this polytope is easy so
there is already some kind of easiness
to both these objects and yeah so we do
exactly what I at a high level suggested
we we look at the supremum over the
polytope and of this quantity and that's
our generalization of the capacity it
looks simple but it took us a long time
to arrive at that this what is the right
notion of capacity which even make sense
I think me my hair will talk about a
different way to arrive at something
similar well said capacity the way the
way you wrote is depending on source
become volatile so capacity in general
as a function of the exponent is low
concave this is not convex optimization
anymore yeah yeah yeah okay so I have
what I've done is added a supremum term
here which in some sense was missing
from garages thing because it got
absorbed by this additional structure
that matching had so if I go back to
this
so what they tell you over to understand
so it's supposed to be realized on their
on the extreme points of the protocol
because I know the capacities look okay
but this is not the usual notion of
capacity yeah so just I wanted to show
you this again that we had a problem in
which there was something outside of
this infimum it disappeared here in this
formula right and I think that's an
important thing to note so what we did
was we basically recovered what was what
should have been here which allows us to
then generalize it to the setting if you
just write it like this it's not clear
but here you are using the fact that
this has this property that the columns
sum up to one so you can remove that
optimization but in general you can't
so this is our relaxation this this is
joint work with the diamond structure
from a couple of years ago and we also
proved the theorem which is that this
quantity is some kind of a relaxation to
the quantity that you would like in
particular it's finite finite you know
whenever may be here we supports a real
stable polynomial and it depends only on
B ok this should be here sorry
however they're mean so yeah this this
as I said that this is once we are right
there this is this is a couple of pages
and follows you know essentially from
past work on which is which was a lot I
mean you know real stable polynomials
the question that was not at all clear
was how do you compute this object and
that's what I think I'm going to spend a
little bit of time on in in the
remaining of my talk and if somebody's
really interested in seeing the proof of
this I can just go during the question
questions yeah so what is that what is
the question what's the issue here well
this is an optimization problem over a
polytope where theta could be any point
inside this poly tope and this is really
what the dual looks like as I said that
this is not a convex this is not a
convex optimization problem it is convex
after the hyperbolic substitution but we
would really like to we have an
algorithm which is able to compute this
object or the value or a point for any
point inside this point could also be on
the boundary yes Oh in this
no no it's a I just simplified the term
yeah yeah there's a more complicated
theorem you have seen the paper so you
know that this is just yeah it's it's
not real stability it's something weaker
than that
yeah M is basically to the end e to the
yeah yeah
but if you need this yeah this is like
yeah so any I'm not gonna focus so much
on this I presume NEMA will talk or you
know talk more about let me focus on the
computability which i think is is
important and it gives it I mean that's
what makes these these results useful in
some sense
besides inequalities
I'm gonna skip these proofs and you see
it's not so much I mean the entropy
interpretation gives you one inequality
and guru which is resolved gives you the
other inequality okay let's get to
compute ability of these so our goal in
the next ten minutes is to solve this
optimization problem which is
parametrized by theta so theta is a
parameter and the optimization problem
involves this and we are given an Oracle
to evaluate P at any given point and
we're also given us let's say you'll
have to use some properties about this
where the point lies you know so what is
the polytope what's the structure of the
phone Ito and there's a very generic
method to solve convex optimization
problems which is called the ellipsoid
method so let me just quickly review
that for the mathematicians in the
audience so the optimization problem
essentially is first reduced to just a
search problem where you're given some
number a and either you tell me that the
optimum value is at most a plus epsilon
or bigger than a for some given epsilon
and we will like the running time of
this algorithm to depend logarithmically
on 1 over epsilon and the general idea
is the following so first we assume that
the optimal solution lies in some very
large ball or or some ball which is
bounded by some radius R and the value
of the function is also bounded in some
we need these assumptions and we also
need to know what the value of R and F
are for this algorithm to make sense
so the algorithm what it does is it's it
it stops there was a picture here I
don't know why I'm sorry
there's a picture here which I wanted
you to see that you start off with some
kind of ellipsoid or a ball which is
guaranteed to contain the optimal point
this guarantee is kind of I mean you're
searching for this optimal point you
need to know that you have at least have
some idea where where it lies and I know
what the algorithm does is it it returns
the center of this ellipsoid and checks
whether the value of the function that
you have is at most what you're looking
for if so you stop if not we use this
evaluation Oracle for this polynomial to
get the gradient of this function and
then construct a new ellipsoid which is
obtained by cutting the old ellipsoid by
a hyperplane and then looking at the
minimum volume ellipsoid that encloses
this new object and then you stop when
the radius of the ellipsoid becomes
really small because then you know well
you have to prove but then that's you
know you have to stop at some point you
cannot keep doing this forever
so to bound the number of iterations of
this algorithm we we will have to give
bounds on this parameter R F and and
more generally how the ellipsoid method
depends on R F and epsilon so
this is the theorem I mean the proof of
this appears for instance in the book
bag or cello wash and shriver that the
running time of this method by running
time I mean the number the total time it
takes for this algorithm to solve this
problem that either the optimum is at
most a plus epsilon or bigger than a is
bounded by some polynomial in M which is
the number of which is the dimension of
the object T sub F which is the time to
evaluate the function f which in our
case is since the polynomial is you know
simple to evaluate we can evaluate it T
sub gradient of F this is the time to
evaluate the gradient of F and more
importantly and this is what we are
going to focus on is the log of R which
is a radius in which of you know or the
are bound on the optimal point F which
is a bound on the value of the function
and epsilon which is the accuracy so for
this to be a polynomial time algorithm
we need to provide at most an
exponential bound on our F for Epsilon
well our NF okay epsilon
so so here is the you know here is a
problem with this okay let's let's first
do the simple part so this entropy
interpretation actually tells us that
the value of the function which is which
is the bound on F can't be much more so
that's bounded by M and that's that
follows from the following so this is
the function that we wanted to optimize
and we also know through duality that it
has you know it has it has a certain
form
it's an entropy of something and at
least in the case where the peas are all
one let's say we can bound the entropy
of an distribution on at least let it on
at most 2 to the M vertices by the log
of that which is M so this is not quite
correct but this is morally correct
because if I look at go back to the
multi linear setting where we just have
you know 0 1 points then the number of
such point cannot be more than 2 to the
M because we are in M dimensions and an
entropy maximizing distribution on that
is that most so because of duality we
can get this bound that the FF is not
too large so this is the easy part but
it does use this duality the issue
becomes bounding R and one of the things
that you can already notice is that as
this point starts to go closer and
closer to the boundary what starts to
happen is that the optimal solution
necessarily has to go to infinity and
the reason is that if this point was
actually on this boundary then none of
these vertices should have any
probability mass on them right and
because the probability mass is
controlled by an exponential the
exponential can never be 0 unless the
point is at infinity so it is
necessarily true that this point Y star
must be at infinity as you're
approaching close to the bow
so now if you were to run this algorithm
for some value of theta which is really
really close to the boundary you expect
this R to become larger and larger so
you cannot really expect this to be a
polynomial time okay so this was handled
in fact it's it's I think it's a more
non-trivial part of this paper by
Gurewitz and Sanborn it's key that I
don't know if I got the date right but
this is where they give an algorithm for
mixed discriminate the bulk of the paper
is in some sense essentially trying to
prove something like this implicitly or
even explicitly right and it was also
used in a results of Jeff Kahn and KO a
bunch of them where they try to
understand hard core distributions on
matching sin graphs and it turns out
that there is this decay of correlation
between the edges they pick random
matching according to the hardcore
distribution the correlation between
these edges decays with respect to the
with respect to the distance between
these edges if the hardcore distribution
has some nice properties so it's not
true for any so these things were used
and I guess in the TCS community they
were used or discovered in the context
of spanning tree polytope in approaches
to things like TSP and a TSP by cheyenne
and others
so we have been with more thing we in
2014 we actually we're not looking at
this capacity problem but we were
interested in the Maxine trophy problem
and what we proved was that something
very nice happens that if the point
theta is in the interior of the polytope
where what it means is that you can put
a ball of radius ETA around this point
and this ball is entirely contained
inside the polytope then R can be
bounded by some polynomial in 1 over ETA
well this is a nice result
it still doesn't help us solve this
problem because here we cannot really
guarantee that the point theta will
always be ETA away from the boundary and
actually the bigger problem than saying
this optimal solution does lie at
infinity so we really cannot compute the
optimal solution with what we can do is
compute something which is an
approximate solution so it's enough to
find a y so that this function here s
theta Y which is this thing inside the
infimum is no more than the optimal
value plus some Epsilon
and there is no reason for such a y to
be at infinity such a y could be
potentially much closer in a smaller
ball and that's what we that's what we
proved in a in a recent result that
under some very generic general
assumptions on the polytope we can prove
that there is always an epsilon
approximating point which lies in a ball
of radius M times something like poly
log 1 over Epsilon and this allows us to
at least bypass this issue of the
bounding box which ellipsoid method
requires
okay couple of minutes so I'll maybe
just tell you I'll show you
this proof it's much simpler this proof
is more complicated and has a lot of
lots of details so let me in the next
couple of nails some idea as to what is
the interesting aspect of proving such a
theorem so what I'm going to show you is
this all result with mohit which which
tells us that if the point is
sufficiently in the interior of the
polytope you can recover a bound on the
optimal solution of the dual which is
bounded by M over ETA and you can see
how general this result is so we will
use this fact that entropy over a
discrete set of size at most 2 to the M
is at most M is something we have used
and and this in particular implies that
the dual at the optimal point lambda
star is bounded by M and if I from this
I I can easily deduce that for each each
matching or in this case each set s each
vertex of the polytope it satisfies this
inequality that the inner product of the
optimal dual point with this given point
theta minus the inner product of the
optimal dual point with respect to the
indicator vector of a particular vertex
is at most M and this starts feeling
like some kind of polarity is going on
and that's indeed what is the case you
can just rewrite this equation and argue
that the inner product of the vector
minus lambda star by M with v minus
theta where v is any point inside the
polytope is bounded by one so if for a
moment you assume that theta is theta is
0 or theta is the origin then this
immediately implies that the point minus
lambda star by M is in the polar of the
convex
it's a very elementary convex geometry
and I claim this is enough for us to
establish some bound the fact that the
optimal point lies in the polar of the
polytope roughly and the fact that there
is a small ball that is contained
contained inside the polytope
immediately imply about the reason is
that if you have a polytope in which
some ball lies inside then the polar of
this pollito is contained in the polar
of the ball okay and we know what the
polar of the ball looks like we know
that if since this ball has radius at
least ETA we know that the polar of the
ball has radius at most M over 1 over
ETA so we knew that minus lambda star by
M lies somewhere here and this object
lies here and I know what the bound of
you know this is of radius at most 1 by
ETA so we get that the the l2 norm of
lambda star is at most M by ETA at least
you have some bound and so all the
previous arguments that I mentioned
including guru bits is result or or con
Jeff Kant's result they heavily use the
structure of the polytope they also get
slightly better bounds but it's not
clear all their structure is really
necessary and that's what our next
result shows which which I'm going to
have to skip with very simple geometry
okay so let's let's just yeah I'll just
skip through this and happy to answer
questions indeed let me just conclude in
this talk we we looked at a problem of
you know accounting problem which was
motivation at least for me came from
machine learning and what we did was we
looked at Guru it says capacity
generalized it to this setting
and I guess in this entropy was a
crucial ingredient understanding guru
the result from entropy point of view
was really useful and the end result was
the deterministic approximate counting
algorithm for a wide variety of problems
and interestingly also includes this
object called the brass camp deep
constant for the rank one case or you
know no file is the expert here on that
which which is a very interesting
constant and it's computability is known
only for this rank one case and
essentially through through these
methods there is no other way to compute
this constants arising in this
inequality other than coming up with
algorithms like the one I showed you
thank you so far so I guess a couple of
questions that arise given that these
algorithms are actually useful for
machine learning it's actually useful to
have faster algorithms compared to
ellipsoid method and so one direction
could be to come up with you know are
there versions of scaling type
algorithms for this general setting and
finally as I mentioned and this comment
is a bit mysterious but it does relate
to this vast complete problem is that I
mean capacity is really not a convex
optimization problem it is in a very
elementary from form a geodesic 'le
convex optimization problem and this is
this holds more generally and so if you
want to make progress in estimating
brass cam clip constant for higher rank
case which is useful in various
theoretical computer science and
mathematical settings we would be we
will need to generalize much of what I
taught on this on these slides to the
setting of early money and manifolds and
I can talk about it offline and with
this I thank you for your attention and
take any questions
[Applause]
from the practical point of view for
finish so you need to compute those
probabilities on certain supports for
which supports you can do what kind of
restriction on the support no
restriction not be much yeah yeah so
this is the precise statement that the
support is described by some poly tope I
don't need to know the inequalities of
the polytope all I need to know is that
the coefficients in the inequalities of
this poly tope are bound yes well the
phases these are the these are the
inequalities that describe the phases
supporting inequalities so what I want
is the following once again that if this
polytope is described by a bunch of
inequalities as long as there is some
way to describe this poly tope in a
manner so that each supporting
hyperplane the numbers that appear in
that are bounded so let's assume
everything is an integer to put some
kind of a scale to it if all these
numbers are bounded by some number M
then the bound depends or normally on
and in all combinatorial polytopes that
you can imagine this is true you'll have
to be really creative to come up with
polytopes where the hyperplane
inequalities require exponentially sized
numbers in the dimension so this is the
only condition that we need actually to
establish epsilon approximate solutions
another way to compute this probability
would do exist I associate the
polynomial which is would say multi
linear case which is one as those
monomials and efficient and zero and
taken to that product in detail okay so
and if the problem under happened to be
would say state
whoa concave then you can apply you can
apply the same yeah yeah okay so this
one's probably do the case when support
this is a Metroid yes that's right and
you will get better so will you get in
this strategy would get better well I
don't think so
I mean competition you can do the same
stuff pretty much yeah so for Metroid's
so well for real stable polynomials you
get something more general called jump
systems I guess and and and it is true
and I think it follows from some works
which were you know previous works that
we used that the Newton polytopes of
real stable polynomials have this
property that they're defining
inequalities have coefficients which are
0 1 or minus 1 right this is something
you knew before yeah so that
so all those polytopes are also included
in this but this is much beyond the
metroid structure so yeah
so one thing that wasn't completely
clear so you have to balance this say
different version of capacity M
different problem besides computing the
main quality one also needs an estimate
on this cannon yes well it is manageable
in the settings that cared about which
is you know DPP's are real stable so
determinant or point processes are real
stable because they arises through some
kind of one determinant so going back to
the machine learning applications you
know where if you remember in the first
slide I mentioned the determinantal
formula right so that is yeah so for
that those applications its managing
there is a real demo for somebody who
wants to see all this which is available
from my website so we actually developed
algorithms and use them
any other
okay thank you